Big changes are in store for fans of The Walking
Dead.
In season 9, the series will lose stars Andrew
Lincoln and Lauren Cohan, and a new showrunner
steps in to take the story to new places.
Do these alterations bode well for the AMC
series?
No one knows yet, but a slew of theories and
rumors have hinted at where The Walking Dead
will go next.
Let's unpack the details.
Two brothers fighting
Rick and Daryl's camaraderie has been a core
part of the show for years, but that might
not be the case in season 9.
Rumors have been swirling that Daryl and Rick's
bromance might be compromised over Rick's
controversial decision to spare Negan's life.
Does this mean the two will become enemies
before Rick's final bow?
Not according to Norman Reedus:
"They fight and they disagree on things but
it's like two brothers fighting, they always
have each other's back but they don't necessarily
agree on everything."
A second time jump
According to UPROXX, rumors are circulating
regarding two shifts in time for season 9:
one of a couple years and another longer one
of four or five years.
The second time jump could help further the
decayed tone new showrunner Angela Kang previously
teased to Entertainment Weekly, saying,
"We'll explore what happened as man-made objects
and structures break down.
Infrastructure like roads and bridges are
changing and crumbling.
And we'll also explore what happens as resources
are getting low."
New loves
Along with a hefty bump in pay, Reedus will
receive top billing once Andrew Lincoln makes
his exit.
With that sort of scrutiny, it's hard not
to wonder if fans will finally see Daryl make
a love connection in season 9.
There are many theories, rumors, and requests
regarding Daryl's future, from a deeper connection
to Carol to a brand new love interest.
The Hollywood Reporter even posed a compelling
possibility: what if Daryl finds a man to
love?
The trade suggested a love connection between
him and Aaron.
"Whether we make it or not, we do it together.
We have to."
He's not the only one with a possible new
romance; the Nerdist has theorized that Alden,
one of the reformed Saviors, might be the
tv version of the comics' Dante—which might
mean that he could be a new romantic partner
for Maggie.
One definitely confirmed love story is between
Carol and King Ezekiel.
Photos from the new season showed Carol and
the king sharing a tender moment, and a subsequent
trailer shows the two sharing a smooch.
Father Gabriel's second sight
After the trials he endured in season 8, it's
looking like Father Gabriel will step confidently
into the role of holy man once the new episodes
premiere.
Leaked images reveal Gabriel, who looks to
be completely blind in one eye, donning a
classic-looking Southern preacher outfit.
Whatever he lacks in physical sight, he may
make up for with religious clarity.
According to BleedingCool, Gabriel will be
the one helping Jadis transition to her new
home in Alexandria.
A new leader
With Rick's death presumably looming, speculation
regarding Daryl's leadership role has grown,
but as Norman Reedus told TVLine, the rumors
of Daryl taking over for Rick are just not
true.
"That's not a true story.
Rick is the quarterback of this football team,
he's always been, he always will…"
So if Daryl won't be taking over as leader,
who will?
Well, there's been a worthy successor under
our noses this entire time.
Rick himself has already said who he wants
to take over for him as leader if anything
happens:
"And if it's me who doesn't make it, you're
going to have to lead the others forward.
Because you're the one who can."
It's an idea that's backed up by what Angela
Kang told EW about the female characters.
"We're going to see our women really step
up.
And we're gonna show a lot of stories about
leadership with Maggie, with Michonne, with
Carol.
And they're gonna go toe to toe with each
other and with our men."
Unfortunately, if Michonne does step up as
leader, it may not be forever.
Danai Gurira's star is steadily on the rise
with plenty of movie roles, which puts her
continued Walking Dead future in question.
When pressed on Michonne's future in Alexandria,
the new showrunner said Gurira is "definitely
a series regular this season."
As for what happens after season 9, though,
Kang said plainly, "that is out of my realm."
A new bat, man
The question of how Rick Grimes will be written
out of The Walking Dead's ninth season still
looms large.
Will he live?
Will he die?
Will he simply wander off into the wilderness
to allow for cameos in later seasons?
Lincoln has confirmed that he's coming back
with the intention of directing an episode
in Season 10, but as for an actual appearance
as Rick?
No one knows.
But one thing we do know is that he'll be
using the time he has left to brutalize some
more zombies with a shiny new weapon inspired
by none other than his arch-nemesis Negan.
Promotional materials for the new season show
a grey-bearded Rick Grimes toying with a bat-like
weapon.
From the show's previews, it's clear he knows
just how to use it, too.
A dead deputy returns
Of all the long-lost characters who could
be brought back into The Walking Dead's fold
for season 9, the return of Jon Bernthal's
Shane was probably the least expected.
After all, he's been dead for over six seasons,
and Bernthal has had plenty of other roles
to keep him busy in the meantime.
However, the actor was spotted near the Atlanta,
Georgia area during the season's summer production.
His appearance set off a rash of speculation
that he might be making a cameo as Lincoln
preps for his exit.
Bernthal's return to the show was confirmed
soon after, though the exact details of his
role reprisal have been kept close to the
vest.
Frenemies
Rick's decision to let Negan live after the
All Out War with the Saviors might come back
to bite him in more ways than one.
Not only has he earned the ire of his friends
with this moment of undeserved mercy, but
now he's going to have to actually deal with
Negan.
Although, Kang has revealed that the former
enemies might have a lot more in common than
one might expect.
"Rick goes down there and it's part therapy
and part gloating, like they're just trying
to work their way through it.
They both feel, in some ways, like dinosaurs
after the war."
Rick has already been known to have trouble
making solid leadership decisions in the past,
so one has to imagine that having Negan in
his ear probably won't be too helpful.
Maggie's happy ending?
Even though Cohan will be departing the show,
things might just be looking up for Maggie
in the new season.
The previews for season 9 show that her baby
will finally join the world after so many
seasons of Maggie's pregnancy.
With Lauren Cohan's impending exit from the
series ahead though, fans might be tempted
to fear for Maggie's well-being.
However, Cohan has hinted that her character's
story isn't over.
In other words, Maggie might someday make
a comeback, so don't count her out just yet.
Unfriendly new faces
With two major characters on the way out and
a lot of time-hopping ahead, it's probably
no surprise that season 9 will introduce a
bevy of new characters.
For starters, there's Samantha Morton as Alpha,
the leader of a group of creepy zombie-impersonators
called the Whisperers.
She'll be joined by Ryan Hurst as Alpha's
second-in-command, Beta, and Cassady McClincy
as Lydia, Alpha's daughter.
The show will also introduce Brett Butler
and John Finn as Tammy and Earl, a pair of
Hilltop residents.
Meanwhile, Eleanor Matsuura and Nadia Hilker
will star as Yumiko and Magna, two more characters
straight from the comics.
Other names joining the fold are Lauren Ridloff
as Connie and Dan Fogler as Luke.
We'll just have to wait and see if any of
these new additions are able to fill the void
left by Rick and Maggie.
The helicopter
When Rick originally saw the helicopter overhead
near the beginning of season 8, many thought
it was a hallucination.
But as the tale continued to unravel, audiences
saw that the scavenger Jadis had a connection
to the copter.
The timing of the helicopter's appearance
could be a possible introduction of the Commonwealth
storyline from the comics.
However, it seems that Alpha and the Whisperers
are also on their way, so season 9 of The
Walking Dead might be blending multiple comic
storylines and timelines together.
The addition of Alpha might finally answer
a long-lingering question about the prevalence
of the letter "A" that's been seen scattered
throughout the prior seasons.
Kang has promised that the significance of
the letter will come into view in season 9,
telling fans that it might have something
to do with Jadis.
Jadis might've made some alliances before,
but does she have another master controlling
that helicopter after all?
We'll see when The Walking Dead season 9 arrives
on October 7.